[Music]
something I really want to tell you I
was having lunch with a friend of mine
Sara she's a lady ah we were the other
day out strip-mall Panera don't worry
about it
and get this I asked her if she wanted
to split a dessert with me but listen to
that she goes I can't I know this kind
of sounds like the first act of a Dannon
yogurt commercial but Sara tannin creme
brulee has 40% less fat and calories
than the leading competitor how's the
taste to vine but stay with me she told
me she couldn't get a dessert because
she was feeling fat and quote I hate my
body right now
that actually happened here's what's
crazy that's the correct response could
empathy you're not a sociopath here's
what's crazy my friend Sara has got a
great body she's what I call a thicker
milkshake I love a thicker milkshake
that's just more milkshake more ice
cream that's a good thing I just wish
you would be happy with that don't get
me wrong I know it's not that he's
either parts of my body that I wish were
different I mean for a man I have some
pretty wide childbearing hips that's the
part that woke everybody up in a lot of
photographs I get what I call boob
shadow
and there are so many malls on my back
it looks like the night sky but I've
known hundreds well two or three women
the thought that was terrific and they
let me know and that appreciation helped
me see myself as the matronly star 'back
giant that I am and that's my point
whatever your body type is I promise you
someone is into it just exactly how you
are whatever you got going on
someone out there wants to get down with
it isn't that great news
and it's listen to me if you're at home
watching this thinking the ultra-thin
model type is the standard favorite of
beauty in this world do me a favor heave
your vogue subscription into an active
volcano and get that [ __ ] out of your
brain
big small thin tall it doesn't matter
someone wants to buy what you're selling
you just need to find it and you can't
this is the internet age the people who
love your body are one click away how
lucky is that back in like medieval
times if you were Julie the girl with
the big butt you just had to hope and
pray there was one dude in your little
village that loved big butts walking by
real slow knees like hawk beholden yawn
the distance a maiden with a rump like a
pumpkin I love a good rump Caen
[Applause]
but even if you did find that guy that
loved a good rump c'n then he had to
Hope had survived the Black Plague the
Crusades or that one time the entire
village thought he was practicing
witchcraft no normal man loves rumps
that big he must be in league with the
devil why was that Robin Williams
pumpkin Jack Hoffman but here in 2014
modern day Julie doesn't have to hope
for [ __ ] just with one low angle profile
picture her beautiful big butt got 480
Instagram likes and one Facebook poke
and I don't mean on lock thank you thank
you
I mean case in point that's what I like
ladies with curves not only are they
sexy but it's probably an indicator that
they like sleeping and as much as I do I
can't be dating a girl with a tan and
ABS cuz that's probably an indicator
that she wants to get up at 5:00 a.m.
and do lunches the same goes for me I'm
soft
I don't mind I'm a soft man and that's
an advertisement to everyone I don't
want to go to spin class
Saturday's are for pancakes say it loud
I'm soft and proud I don't care and I'm
not the only one who feels this way
you feel like you're big go to a museum
rubenesque women have been popular is it
all of known time pretty sure it's all
of known time curving fun lots of ups
and downs with the brush swooshes and
swirls that's a good time to paint
here's my boy love your body if you're
short get into it find a guy whose
physical ideal is a gal he can put on
her shoulders at Bonnaroo before you go
back to the hotel for at all on short
boner room lots of guys like short girls
just like oh so sweet bro she's tiny
last night she just fell asleep in my
arms she's breathing up and down like a
little baby squirrel short oh and if
you're tall don't be like oh I want to
be a baby squirrel you don't have to be
a baby squirrel because guess what your
Amazonian just go find a guy that likes
that find a partner who sees you and
dreams of making an army of long tall
babies who in the summers can clean your
gutters might also serve you and I see
you and not just because you understand
my fear of door jambs and low-hanging
plants tall short thick thin just own it
every girl I've ever met with curly hair
once straight hair every girl with
straight hair is always curling it how
about this spend the time you would have
spent curling or straightening King
somebody who likes you the way you are
[Applause]
[Music]